i can't wait i've been this was the
first song i wrote for the album so i
wrote this early 2019 so i've been
sitting on it for so long not that i
knew it would end up being the first
single or anything but that no i'm more
desperate to get this record out than
anyone like really really that you know
just i can't wait for it just to be out
and be done and for it to sort of begin
the last
chapter of what i've been going through
the whole album is sort of dedicated to
my son more than anything but yeah it's
it's about um you know my relationship
with his dad and with him but also you
know the relationship i have with myself
and stuff like that is like you could be
in like you know a discussion or
disagreement or a full-blown row if you
want not that me and his dad ever used
to do that but um
even if you're the one that's sort of
initiating the discussion it's sort of
be like well hang on a minute go easy on
me you know it's not my fault so it's
just sort of really about that in in the
way that you know the decision that i
made really so
yeah he's into like gamers
like he likes flamingo and all them lot
like i mean he think i don't know like
yeah he ain't bothered by me at all
he does not care at all all he is is
like you're so busy all the time now
like
no he doesn't care and he's always
comparing
the other day he was telling me how many
youtube followers i have is nowhere near
as many as the big gamers i was like
okay cheers kid thank you
but yeah no he doesn't really he's not
really aware of it yet but um oh nice
i've got them off in me room great in
the office
he's coming to a couple of um sort of
work things i have coming up and we'll
see but i'm sure he'll just be like well
i think flamingo don't like this or like
that like yeah but he's great
he's a very lovely lovely little boy i
would love to do a big proper tour again
um i wouldn't do it quite as long as i
did it last time it was something like
130 odd shows in like less than 18
months but um i would love to do that
but all the covert rules are different
everywhere like you know and the sort of
like you know the rates of the infection
the rates of vaccine whatever it's just
it's just it makes me nervous trying to
plan a world tour
globally
when
it feels like no one's really on the
same page um and the last thing i would
ever want to do is capture any shows
again you know so
i'm up for either as long as i get to do
something it's it's i'm good i'm not
neighbors with harry and megan they did
stay near where i am based in la for a
while but um they're down in santa
barbara i think um and yes katie used to
um but she's yeah drink over everyone
left it feels like um
but um yeah though
they're all i saw harry and megan when
they was here just very briefly and i
really love them and um katie's great
i've known katie for years she was um
she was a big fan of mine the first time
i was ever on um
george holland you know like is to go
have blown up yeah we've been friends
for years but no no raging no raging
parties not at all no